getting EU leaders to sign off the
brexit deal is the easy bit the real
battles will start back at home and a
wombat venture he might prove decisive
is the former Conservative Party leader
in Duncan Smith who joins us there now
thank you very much for being on the
show so first things first just to be
clear can you support Teresa Mays deal
well I haven't seen the final bit of the
deal and whether anything's changed or
not but what I saw over the last week
and a half to two weeks makes it very
very difficult for somebody like me the
support this deal it seems to me that
far too much has been given to the
European Union and far too little seems
to ally itself with our commitments both
at the lacs now speech which she made
and more importantly in some senses the
manifesto pledge we made at the last
election and those were very clear that
we take back full control of our laws
our borders and our money and there are
real issues in this that number one
issue of course is the backstop in
Northern Ireland which seeds huge
amounts of power to the European Union
both to the court of justice but also
for the very fact that the Northern
Ireland will be treated differently from
the rest of the UK and we will be stuck
if we go into the backstop in the
customs union obeying all those rules
and regulations so there are many other
issues as well but those those are
immediately what were in the paper and
don't appear to have changed there's
another one - Sophie which is quite
important I was looking again at the
report and I noticed that in the area
where the government talks about ending
freedom of movement I have to say having
written a paper on this I don't really
think that's correct because it now
talks in there buried in there that
there would be social security
coordination between us and the EU I
think when you strip out the language
what that actually means is that we are
prepared to cede to citizens of the
European Union an almost immediate right
to claim benefits and this is called
huge damage to many many on low incomes
who are competing with them when they
find that they come in on very low
salaries and claim all the benefits I
mean it cost
for those on low-income for the UK
taxpayer it cost us about 500 million
pounds in the last year of record so
these are very very big issues and
questions whether we really are going to
seriously think about ending freedom of
movement
I just really pin you down on the
specifics of my question you say it's be
very difficult to support the Prime
Minister's deal as it stands will you
vote for it or against it I certainly
won't be waiting for word and I'm more
likely to vote against it but as I say
I'll see what comes back if anything's
changed I don't believe anything much
has changed in fact I think there's one
area which makes it even more difficult
which is that we seem to have ceded the
right of Spain to have a say over what
gibraltars future trading relationship
will be whether it's exactly the same as
the UK's now that's being dressed up a
bit but the reality is when you peel it
away Spain is now saying that they have
a major concession and I seriously
wonder whether if that is the case we
haven't also in a sense abandoned
Gibraltar as well as we have abandoned
so many other things in the course this
negotiation okay I mean number 10 are
denying that they say that it's not a
concession it's just a restatement of
what was already agreed but I just want
to take a quick step back because the
deal on the table proposes that we would
end free movement of people it says that
you know they hope to be able to conduct
their own trade deals they hope that the
backstop in Ireland will never come into
force and that there may be
technological ways of solving that
border problem so I know it's not
perfect it's not exactly what you wanted
but don't you have to compromise I'm
assure you this is the kind of deal
where you're a skeptics a few years ago
would have bitten the PM's arm off to
get
well not really no and you say
compromise but we have compromised many
of us are compromised you know when you
think back to it back in December where
I think it all went wrong we were
persuaded at the time to compromise over
the fact that we gave the EU a
commitment to 39 billion and also we
agreed to this ludicrous backstop which
is very damaging to the Union now that
was all done on the basis that it
wouldn't be legally binding and that we
would immediately move to trade
negotiations which were then complete
before we had to vote on all this well
we never did move to trade negotiations
and they are binding as you see now in
the withdrawal agreement the only
binding legal text is the withdrawal
agreement and in it you have the
backstop and it's bound in that we will
pay them 39 billion not hinged on
whether we get a trade deal it's bound
in and so the big problem is there have
been major compromises made and we fully
understand I fully understand you need
to compromise but to compromise and give
away all of the important things that
the EU wants without actually getting
anything other than a general statement
about what might happen to us is really
really damaging and let me just come
back to this backstop Sophie because
it's really really important if the
backstop we are assured now by the Prime
Minister that the EU does not want us in
the backstop
we are assured that we don't want to be
in the backstop in fact the Chancellor
says it's a terrible terrible mess the
backstop and we are told categorically
now because the Irish say they will not
ever ever have a hard border regardless
what the deal is so if all those
assurances are that we will never go
into the backstop why in Hell's name is
the backstop sitting as a legal text
which means if we leave without any
agreement without a future trade deal we
are bound to go into the backstop or
they will force us into an extension of
the implementation period which will
cost us you know tens and tens of
billions of pounds so I really don't
think then it's any good to give us
reassurances when we should have these
bound into the drawer agreement briefly
mr. Duncan Smith because we are running
out of time Dominic Reilly former brexit
secretary suggested that the deal on the
table is worse than remaining
in the EU Dean share his view what would
be worse staying in the EU or adopting
the deal on the table well I don't want
to stand the EU I campaign to voted to
leave the EU I don't believe that so far
this deal delivers on what the British
people really voted for you know take
back control your borders your laws your
money I think it is seeded too much
control I believe the government needs
to go back and say things like the
backstop
we simply cannot agree it and you must
take all of that reference out don't
things to do the court of justice that
would make this a better deal but right
now the balance is definitely tilted
against this being a deal I'm afraid
that delivers on what the government
said they would deliver which is leaving
the European Union and setting out to be
able to do our own trade deals we won't
be able to do our own trade deals if
were bound into the customs union that
is single one of the most important
things that people voted for and just
finally mr. Duncan Smith though we heard
this week didn't we that the prominent
conservative MP writes that here John
Hayes was to be given a knighthood lots
of speculation there that this was a new
dealing buyer number 10 I will just
wondered there's a flaming ringing for
you a certain Duncan Smith perhaps that
would make you back the deal this is not
April Fool is it can I just say when it
comes to John Hayes he's an old friend
and he's been a loyal he's been a loyal
minister of a government and I have to
say he deserves a night to it I am over
the moon and very happy for him and his
wife Susan and I give them my fullest
congratulations as do you by the way all
of my colleagues he's a really good man
and and I think if you can't if we can't
accept generously that award is given to
a good decent person then I think that
says less of us I'm absolutely over the
moon about it but there's nothing okay
don't worry in Dhaka thank you very much
to be with us this morning